[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hi, everybody.
I guess I'm the one who gets
to do the introduction here,
so we were just
talking a little while
ago about how science
fiction, in particular, is
a genre with a couple of
competing qualities about it.
On one hand, good
science fiction
is about the time and
place it's written,
thousands of years
in the future.
But on the other
hand, you're not
supposed to think so
while you're reading it.
And the author that you're
here to see today, Ann Leckie,
is extremely good at
both sides of that coin.
And so let's hear her
talk about her new book.
[APPLAUSE]
ANN LECKIE: Hello.
It's good to see everybody here.
Look at you all.
This is wonderful.
I guess I'll start, if
everybody is agreeable,
with reading a little
bit from the new book.
Yeah?
So this book is,
in a lot of ways,
it's set in the same
universe as the trilogy,
but it's rather different
from the trilogy.
I felt like I needed kind of
a break from that intensity,
and so I wanted to
write something,
a little more of a romp,
something a little more
relaxing after that.
So I'm going to start now
at the very beginning,
but a little in.
And what's happening is the
main character, Ingray--
she has spent literally
every space penny
she has trying to spring
a notorious criminal
from the euphemistically named
prison, Compassionate Release.
Compassionate Removal--
please excuse me.
And she's done this,
and this person
has been delivered
to her in a crate,
in a suspension pod, which in
some ways, is a relief to her,
because she doesn't
have to explain what
she's doing to them quite yet.
And she's taken the
crate to the ship
that she has booked
to take her back home,
and the captain is
having none of it.
He does not want to
take anyone aboard who
is not, like, conscious
and able to say,
yes, I want to go somewhere.
Right?
"Captain Uisine stared
at her over the crate.
'I am on the very
edge,' he said, finally,
'of refunding your passage,
both of the berths you've paid
for, and asking you
to leave this bay.
I haven't made up my mind yet,
but I'll tell you one thing.
There's no way you're
bringing that person--
Pahlad Budrakim you said--
aboard my ship still
in that suspension pod.
And considering you expected
to meet him awake and unfrozen,
you won't have any objection
to thawing him out now,
I presume.'
'Will you take us aboard, then?'
'I'll consider taking
you aboard, then.
Pahlad Budrakim can
do as he likes.'
A moment's thought.
'If he doesn't want
to come aboard,
I'll refund you airfare.'
It could have been
worse, Ingray supposed.
It was some sort
of chance, anyway.
Captain Uisine put his
other hand on the crate.
'Step back, Excellency.
You don't want your
foot caught under this.'
Ingray stepped back, and the
crate settled to the floor
with a thunk.
'Do you know if this person
has ever been in suspension
before?'
Ingray picked up
her jacket and bag
and sandals off the crate lid.
'No, why?' Captain Uisine
touched the crate's latches
and carefully slid
the lid aside.
'He might panic if he
doesn't know what to expect.
A little help would be nice.'
Ingray dropped her
sandals and bag,
pulled her jacket
on, and then helped
brace the lid as
Captain Uisine tilted it
and let it slide down to
rest against the crate.
Captain Uisine
looked for a moment
at the smooth, black
surface of the pod,
then slid open the
pod's control panel.
'Everything looks
good,' he said,
as a giant black spider
scuttled out of the airlock,
nearly a meter high, a rolled
up blanket clutched in one hairy
appendage.
Weirdly, disturbingly
graceful, it skittered up
to Captain Uisine
and stopped, turned
one of its far too many
stalked eyes toward Ingray--
no, it wasn't a spider.
It was something else.
'Um,' said Ingray.
'That's-- is that a spider?'
She didn't know why the back
of her neck was prickling.
She didn't mind spiders, but
this thing was so unsettling.
Its legs were jointed
wrong, she realized,
and its eyestalk sprouted right
out of its blob of a body.
There was no waist, no
head, and something else
was wrong, though she
couldn't quite say what.
'Of course, it's not a spider,'
replied Captain Uisine,
still frowning at
the suspension pod.
'You don't get spiders
with half-meter bodies
or two-meter legspans or not,
you know, unaugmented ones.
But this isn't a spider.'
He looked up.
'But it's kind of like a spider.
I'll grant you that.
Do you have a problem
with spiders, Excellency?'
The not-spider's body
trembled gelatinously,
stretched to become
oblong rather than round,
and four extra legs slid
out to touch the bay floor.
Does that help?
Seeing the thing change
shape was somehow
even more disturbing, but
she refused to step back,
even though she wanted to.
'Not really, and I don't
mind spiders at all.
It's just this looks so so
organic, except in a wrong,
squishy, itchy sort of way.'
'Well, yes,' said
Captain Uisine,
standing square and
stolid by the open crate,
entirely unbothered by the
spidery thing beside him.
'A lot of it is.
Some people find it unsettling,
and apparently, you're
one of them.
But it's just a biomech.
You'll get used to
it after a few days,
or if you don't I'll,
keep it out of your way.'
He touched the control
panel, and the smooth surface
of the pod broke open with
a click and slid aside.
For just an instant, Ingray
saw a person lying naked
and motionless, submerged
in a pool of blue fluid,
unevenly cut hair a
tangled mass over half
of her sharp-featured
face, thin, thinner
than she remembered
pictures of Pahlad
Budrakim, the long welt of a
scar along their right flank.
Then, the smooth, glassy
surface of the preserving medium
rippled and billowed as the
person opened their eyes
and sat convulsively
up, choking,
one outthrust arm
smacking hard into Ingray.
Captain Uisine
grabbed her other arm.
'It's all right,' he said,
voice still calm and serious.
The person continued to choke
as blue fluid poured out
of their mouth and nose,
sheeted away from their body
back into the pod.
'It's all right.
Everything's fine.
You're all right.'
The last of the
fluid drained away
from the person's
mouth and nose,
and he gave a
breathy, shaking moan.
'First time?' asked
Captain Uisine,
reaching down for the
blanket the spider mech still
proffered.
The naked person in the
pod closed their eyes,
gasped a few times, and
then her breathing settled.
'Are you all right?' asked
Ingray, in Bantia this time,
the most commonly spoken
language in Hwae System,
though she was fairly
sure Pahlad Budrakim
would've understood Yiir,
which Captain Uisine had used.
Captain Uisine shook
the blanket out
and laid it around the
naked person's shoulders.
'Where am I?' he
asked in Bantia,
voice rough with cold or
fear or something else.
'We're on tour Tyr Siilas
Station in Tyr System,' said
Ingray, and then to Captain
Uisine, 'He asked where he is,
and I told him we're
on Tyr Siilas.'
'How did I get here?'
asked the person sitting in
the suspension pod in Bantia.
By now, the blue fluid
had all drained away
to some reservoir
in the pod itself.
'I paid someone to bring
you out,' said Ingray.
'I'm Ingray Aughskold.'
The person opened
their eyes, then.
'Who?' Well, Ingray had never
really met Pahlad Budrakim
in person, and he was 10 or
more years older than she was
and not likely to have
noticed a very young Aughskold
foster-daughter, not likely to
have known her name when she
had still been a child,
let alone her adult name,
which she'd taken only
months before he'd gone
to Compassionate Removal.
'I'm one of Netano Aughskold's
children,' said Ingray.
'Why?' he asked, a
voice gaining strength,
'would one of Representative
Aughskold's children bring me
anywhere?'
Ingray tried to think of
a simple way to explain
and settled, finally, for,
'You're Pahlad Budrakim.'
He gave a little shake
of their head, a frown.
'Who?'
Ingray suppressed a start
as another spider mech came
skittering out of the airlock.
This one held a large
cup of steaming liquid,
which it passed
to Captain Uisine
before it spun and
returned to the ship.
'Here, Excellency,'
he said in Yiir,
offering it to the person
still sitting in the pod.
'Can you hold this?'
'Here," said the
first spider mech
in a thin, thready
voice in Bantia.
'Can you hold this?'
'Aren't you Pahlad
Budrakim?' asked Ingray,
feeling strangely numb,
except maybe for an unpleasant
sensation in her gut, as though
she was not capable of feeling
any more despair or fear
than she already had today.
The facilitator had
said this was Pahlad.
No, it said it examined the
payment and the merchandise,
and both were what
they should have been.
But surely, that
was the same thing.
'No,' said the person sitting
in the suspension pod.
'I don't even know who that is.'
He noticed the cup Captain
Uisine was proffering.
'Thank you,' he
said, and took it,
cupped it in their hands
as Captain Uisine stopped
the blanket from sliding
off their shoulders.
'Drink some,' said Captain
Uisine, still in Yiir.
'It's serbat.
It'll do you good.'
'Drink it,' said the
spider mech in Bantia.
'It's serbat.
It's good and nutritious.'
What if there had
been a mistake?
This person looked like Pahlad
Budrakim, but also, in a way,
he didn't.
He was thinner certainly,
and Ingray had only
seen him in person once or
twice, and that was years ago.
'You're not Pahlad Budrakim?'
'No,' said the person who
was not Pahlad Budrakim.
'I already said that.'
He took a drink of the serbat.
'Oh, that's good.'
Really, it didn't matter.
Even if this person was
Pahlad, if he was lying to her,
it made no difference.
She couldn't compel
him to go with her back
to her Hwae and not just
because Captain Uisine would
refuse to take him
unless he wanted to go.
Her plan had always
depended on Pahlad
being willing to go along.
'You look a lot like Pahlad
Budrakim,' Ingray said,
still hoping.
'Do I?' he asked, and took
another drink of serbat.
'I guess someone
made a mistake.'
He looked straight
at Ingray then
and said, 'So when a Budrakim
goes to Compassionate Removal,
it's only for show, is it?
They send someone to fish
them out behind the scenes?'
Her expression didn't change,
but her voice was bitter.
Ingray drew breath
to say indignantly,
'No, of course not,' but found
herself struck speechless
by the fact that she had
herself gotten a Budrakim out
of Compassionate Removal.
'No,' she managed, finally.
'No.
I-- you're really
not Pahlad Budrakim?'
'I'm really not,' he said.
'Then who are you?'
asked the spider mech,
though Captain Uisine
hadn't said anything aloud.
The person sitting in the
suspension pod took another
drink of serbat, then said,
'You said we're on Tyr Siilas.'
'Yes,' said the spider mech.
Ingray found she
couldn't speak at all.
'I think I'd rather
not tell you who I am.'
He looked around at the
suspension pod he sat in,
the crate still surrounding
it, and Captain Uisine
at the spider mech beside
the captain around the bay.
'I think I'd like to visit
the incomer's office.'
'Why?' asked Ingray,
almost a cry,
unable to keep her confusion and
her despair out of her voice.
'Unless you have financial
resources we're unaware
of,' said the spider mech, 'you
won't be able to do more than
apply for an indenture.
You may or may not get one, and
unless you have contacts here,
you very probably won't like
what you get if you do.'
'I'll like it better than
Compassionate Removal.'
He drained the last
of their beverage.
'Look on the bright side,'
Captain Uisine said himself
to Ingray in Yiir as he took
the cup from Not Pahlad.
'I'll refund you our passage,
and you'll be able to eat
actual food for the
next couple of days.'"
[APPLAUSE]
So usually, at this
stage, I take questions.
Sometimes I say I could
maybe sing and dance,
but I'm very bad
at those things.
So if anyone has
any questions, I
know there are mics
in the aisles there.
And I will be happy to
answer questions or talk
about whatever people would
like me to talk about.
AUDIENCE: All right, this
kind of a generic question,
but what does your like
writing setup look like?
And what do you do when
you find it hard to write
or are kind of stuck creatively?
ANN LECKIE: So my--
I have a couple of places
that I tend to write.
I have a nice little
office in the basement
that my husband put
together for me.
I have two nice big monitors,
which are the best for editing,
and a nice ergonomic
keyboard, which
I love my ergonomic keyboard.
Sometimes that
doesn't suit where
I'm at, so I will take a
laptop out to the back porch
or to a coffee shop or whatever.
When I'm stuck, very often,
I will spend an hour or two
basically banging my
head on the desk trying
to figure out where the
sentences are that need
to come.
And then very often, I'll
give up and go upstairs
to take a shower.
And there's something
in the shower water.
Usually, that's when I realized
what I needed to have written.
If that doesn't work,
I will go for a walk.
And if the walk doesn't
work, I know it's time
to go to the library, where I
will just walk down the history
and anthropology
shelves and pull off
anything that seems appealing.
And nine times out of 10,
that first stack of books
will have something in it that
was what I was looking for.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Take care.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Could you talk
about your decision
to use the Spivak pronouns,
rather than the female pronoun?
ANN LECKIE: Ah
well, I do use "she"
in this book, but not default,
as I do in the trilogy.
I'm very proud about my
choice in the trilogy.
I'm really pleased with
the effect that it had.
But I also, listening
to conversations
about that among other
people, some folks
pointed out that that usage,
while it does cool things,
also sort of erases a bunch
of different identities.
And I said, that's
an interesting point,
and maybe I want to think
some more about that.
So when it came
to this book, it's
very much like the trilogy.
It's very much not
what the book is about.
But I said, what if
I had a society that
doesn't think of gender as
being obviously a binary the way
our culture tends
to think of it?
This society thinks, obviously,
there are three genders, right?
There are men, women, and neman.
And it's he and she and e.
And I chose the Spivak
pronouns in particular,
because there are
lots to choose from.
There are just many that folks
have suggested and come up
with.
But as it happens, I
actually know some folks, who
use those as their pronouns.
And I thought, well,
that'll be kind of fun,
because then they'll
get to open the book
and say, oh, look, there's
my pronouns being used.
There's people
there, who I could
think of are like me in a way.
I mean, I probably don't
capture their identities,
because that's a
complicated thing.
But it's kind of-- it's
so rewarding and important
to be able to see
that on the page.
So that's why I made that
specific choice, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I know that lots of--
some authors have
talked about how
they write very out
of order, while I've
heard some who were able
to write more in line.
And I was curious how
that goes for you.
Are you in line
with the timeline,
or is it all over the place?
ANN LECKIE: I pretty much
can't write out of order.
I haven't been able
to write out of order,
partly because I don't outline.
And very often,
although I do have
an idea of where I'm
going with a story,
I know where I want to end up,
I often know some signposts.
But the specifics of
how a scene works,
I can't envision
until I've got what
comes before it, because
so many tiny little nuances
of conversation or action
will inform that next scene.
So then, I don't have any ground
to write the next scene from.
So I have never been able to
write very much out of order
at all.
I'm very envious of my friends
who outline very, very--
at a very detailed level.
They write so much faster than
I do, and one of these days,
maybe I'll manage it.
But I've never
been able to do it.
AUDIENCE: To what
extent, if any,
did Iain M. Banks's "Culture"
series and their ascensionship
sort of influence your choice
to sort of feature an ascension
ship as a protagonist in
the Ancillary trilogy?
ANN LECKIE:
Actually, not at all,
because I had not read
Banks until I was very far
along in "Ancillary Justice."
When I did read Banks, I
was like, this is awesome.
And I love that there's actually
somebody who buy stories
with ascensionships, right?
But my work frequently
gets compared
to Banks, which is a
tremendous compliment, but not
a particularly accurate
assessment of my influences,
yeah.
AUDIENCE: Every
writer will choose
some parts of their
world to focus on and pay
less attention to other parts.
In your work, I noticed you
use a lot of off the shelf
sci-fi technology.
Shuttle will get you reliably
from one place to another,
but you don't really
dwell on how it works.
[INAUDIBLE] will
heal any injury.
Was that a conscious decision
to focus less on attack,
more on the social
aspects or wherever?
Can you talk about your
thought process there?
ANN LECKIE: It very much
was a conscious decision.
In some cases, actually,
I've worked out
for myself what my
rationalization is for some
of the sort of magic tech.
But I feel like that's not the
focus of the stories as such.
I like working with
the implications of it
more than with the actual
details of the tech.
So yeah, that was definitely
a conscious choice.
AUDIENCE: How fast do you write?
ANN LECKIE: It really depends.
Ideally, in theory, in theory,
I write at least 1,000 words
a day.
That's ideally.
Some days, I can do
much more than that.
Some days, I'm lucky
to get five words.
Some days, I'm in the
stage of creating,
where actually what I need
to do is read and think,
and no words are coming at all.
And those days are very
scary and frustrating,
but I've discovered that
they're an important part
of the process, because
it doesn't move forward
without those days.
AUDIENCE: So is it
radically different
when you're actively working
on a book versus breaks
in between?
ANN LECKIE: Oh, absolutely.
Very, very different.
And I can-- when I'm
between large projects,
I will go a month or two without
having written anything at all.
And then I'll get super paranoid
and have to remind myself
that, actually, it'll be OK.
Yeah, I'm actually still
working on something,
even if there aren't words.
AUDIENCE: So I'm delighted to
be back in the same universe
and especially in a
different part of it.
I haven't read the book yet.
But when I got to the
end of the trilogy,
I was a little
distraught at the idea
that I might never
actually find out
what's going on inside
the Dyson sphere that's
in the middle of everything.
And I'm wondering,
do you know how much
of the map of this
universe you're eventually
going to write about?
And will we see the inside
of that Dyson sphere
with gloves off at some
point in the future?
ANN LECKIE: Gloves off--
that's very improper.
I, obviously, know a lot
more about the Dyson sphere
than ever ended up on the page.
As to whether or not I'll
write about it, I might.
I have to admit I'm easily
bored, and I'm in a place
right now, where I'm fortunate
to be able to just take off
after whatever's shiny.
And so if that feels
shiny to me, I might.
So I don't know for sure.
There aren't concrete
plans to do it,
but there aren't
concrete plans not to as
well, so I make no promises.
AUDIENCE: So in terms of
your influences in fiction,
what are your influences
outside of science fiction?
ANN LECKIE: Outside
of science fiction--
oh, the inside of
science fiction
is much easier to
answer, isn't it?
I honestly don't know.
Well, I do read quite a lot
of history and anthropology
almost at random.
I find that real
human cultures are
more varied and
nuanced than anything
I could ever put on the page.
And if I want to create
something realistic,
I can't go wrong by looking
at what already exists.
And history, of course, is full
of amazing stories that often
don't end up in school,
because there's--
you don't hear about them when
you're taking your Western civ
course or whatever.
And there's just some
amazing stuff to use there,
so I will read things like that.
I also find I really
enjoy historical fiction
for some similar reasons.
When I'm not working on
a project in particular,
often, I will go and read some
very light historical romances
just as kind of a mental break.
I don't know how much
those influence my writing.
I do know when the second
book in the trilogy came out,
and a bunch of people were
like, wow, this is really weird.
It's very different
from the first book,
and it was one
person in particular,
who DMed me and said, you
know what this really reminds
me of is Patrick O'Brien.
And I said, actually, I
mainlined that entire series
right before I sat
down to write this.
So influences come
in odd places, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if influences
within science fiction
is easier, what
are your influence
within science fiction?
ANN LECKIE: So the
obvious answers
to influences within science
fiction would be as a child,
I read way more Andre
Norton than could possibly
be healthy for a single person.
I suspect that Norton is a
writer, who she doesn't yet
talked about very
much critically,
but I suspect she's had a
profound impact on the field,
because a lot of us grew
up reading her work.
And I couldn't point
to where, but I
don't doubt that her work has
influenced mine very strongly.
Also, especially in the
past 10 or 15 years,
I have become a huge
CJ Cherry fan girl.
Those of you-- who's
another writer, who's
a major figure in the
field, and maybe doesn't get
talked about as much.
I mention her at
every opportunity,
because I think that
should probably change.
Those of you who have read her
Foreigner series, which I love,
it's up to what?
18 books now-- will probably
have noticed there are actually
some deliberate Easter eggs in
the trilogy that are deliberate
hat tips to CJ Cherry.
I just-- I love
her work so much.
I also-- when I was first
starting out seriously writing,
and I realized my visuals
left something to be desired,
I went back and
re-read a large amount
of Jack Vance, whose work
I just admire tremendously.
On a sentence level,
just beautiful writing,
really gorgeous visuals,
and a real, almost sort
of anthropological
knack for creating
tiny little sort of
thumbnail sketches
of bizarre human cultures that
feel absolutely real, where you
say, wow, that's really
weird, and I totally
believe that human
beings would do that.
And these are just little sort
of decorations along the way,
just sort of ornamental stuff.
His work is really fabulous.
AUDIENCE: You talked about--
you just mentioned when
you first started seriously
writing, and so was there--
when you're writing
a first book,
is there a moment that
you sort of go from,
this is something I'm
doing, to, this is going
to be a trilogy in a universe?
How do you get from
not writer to writer?
What was that transition like?
But what was that
transition like for you?
ANN LECKIE: It's almost
one of those things, where
you suddenly look up
and realize that you've
passed a transition.
And I'm going to be flip
and also not flip and say,
the way that you become
a writer is to write.
That's how-- it's
not a helpful answer,
and when I was at the stage
where I was a beginning writer,
and a writer would
say, the way you
become a writer is to write,
I'd be like, oh, thanks.
I didn't know that.
But it actually does.
What happened with
me, and I think
is fairly typical, is I have
actually written two or three
other novels that no one
in this room will ever see,
because they are dreadful.
And they're put
away in a drawer,
but that was part of the
process so that by the time
I came to "Ancillary
Justice," I had already
built up a level of
skill and confidence
that I was able to say, oh,
this is going to be a trilogy,
before I started to write.
I didn't say that
about my first novel,
partly because it
was a NaNoWriMo novel
and partly because I was just--
I had no idea what I was doing.
And it just kind of comes with
time and continuing to do it.
If you're going to be
a writer, you kind of
have to be sort of
bloody minded about it,
because you're not going to
get validation from outside.
You're not going to get--
barring certain
special circumstances
you're not going to get
a certificate that says,
"Now you're a writer."
And you can do everything
right and write
the most beautiful,
gorgeous work
and never have much
in the way of success.
There's no-- so
it's just-- you just
have to sit down and do it.
And after a while,
you do it long enough
that it's sort of part
of what you're doing.
And you say, oh,
now I'm a writer.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you said earlier
that you don't plot or outline
too far ahead.
So then how do
you know that this
is going to be a trilogy
and not two books
or four books or 10 books?
ANN LECKIE: I knew where the
trilogy was going to end up.
I knew where the
trilogy was headed,
and I knew I couldn't
do that in one novel.
But the only specific signposts
I had were for the first novel,
like a couple of scenes
that I knew I wanted to hit.
If I looked too far
ahead, it would just
become way too daunting.
It's like you're up outside
a 100-story building,
like don't look down, right?
You can't do that.
So that's basically--
I can't start writing,
unless I know where
I want to end up.
So that was how that happened.
AUDIENCE: So was it kind
of like you hit some point,
and you're like, OK, this is
enough words for a first book
or enough progression
in the plot?
Somewhere in between?
ANN LECKIE: It's a
little bit more--
once I say to myself, this
is a trilogy, then I'd say--
then I said to
myself, then I need
to make each book have its
own arc, because I think this
should be illegal, actually.
You know when you pick up
a book, and you read it,
and it's the first in a series,
and it ends on a cliffhanger,
and the next book's not
out until next year?
That should be
illegal, straight up.
Yeah.
And I understand why
it happens, especially
when you've got a
really big work,
and the publisher is like, yeah,
this is too big for one volume.
Let's split it in half.
It should still be illegal.
So I said, well, I
know it's a trilogy,
but I also know that I can
write and write and maybe never
even sell the first volume.
So I'm going to carve out
a story that's itself,
that's complete, but
also that can go on
to the rest of the
trilogy that I wanted.
And that was what I aimed at.
AUDIENCE: So something
I was wondering
about earlier when you were
talking about how many--
how much you write in a day
or how many words or whatever,
how much do those words sort of
evolve between the first time
you put them down on a
digital page and the book's
publication?
And do you ever
go back and change
how the details of
something worked out
after you write the next parts?
ANN LECKIE: Oh, yes.
Almost always.
I will often start my days
writing with going back
over what I wrote the day
before, if nothing else,
to get kind of a running
start on what I did.
But I'll always be adjusting
sentences and changing things.
And of course, it also happens
that I'll be in the shower
and go, oh, my gosh.
Five chapters ago, I need
to change this detail.
And then I'll have to
run downstairs and change
the thing, and hopefully,
I didn't drip too much
on the keyboard.
So there is a fair amount
of changing, but I also--
I do work very
slowly moving ahead.
So I don't do quite as much
ripping out and completely
changing things as I did
when I first started out.
When I first started
out, I was NaNoWriMoing,
so it was like,
plunge right ahead.
Don't stop.
Don't think.
Just keep typing.
And that made for
a lot of, yeah,
that whole 60 pages has to go.
So I'm a lot more careful, but
there's always lots of tweaking
and adjusting and
deleting and adding.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about sense and nonsense, maybe
pseudosense, mainly the Presger
Translators and the Geck
ambassador.
Is that hard to write,
fun to write, both?
ANN LECKIE: It's both.
It's both.
They were so fun to write.
I loved writing them.
I knew that they were
going to be kind of absurd,
but when translator
[INAUDIBLE] came on stage
and uttered her
first couple lines.
And then I was like, oh, this
is going somewhere really weird.
And I was like, yeah, I'm
just going to lean into that.
And it was a lot of fun.
And actually, I guess this
has potential spoilers.
When I realized how brief a time
she was going to be on stage,
I was very unhappy.
And I said, well, I'm just
going have to change this.
And I tried to change it, and
it was going to break the book.
And I said, I can't do it.
So I said, well,
in the third book,
I know Translator
Zeiat's coming,
so I'm going to have her
on stage every minute I can
and get all the fun
I can out of her.
So they turned out to be
such a delight to write.
But it was also very
difficult, because that's
the kind of thing that you can
kind of get wrong, if you--
it's like a tightrope.
You step to either
side, and it falls flat.
AUDIENCE: Did you find yourself
having to get into a particular
mindspace to write them?
ANN LECKIE: Yeah, kind of, yeah.
Yeah.
It was kind of an
odd space, yeah.
They were a lot of fun.
They were-- I really--
I miss them of all the-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Fair enough.
And were there any specific
inspirations for those?
ANN LECKIE: I didn't
think there were,
but somebody messaged
me at one point
and said, did you
read Lloyd Alexander's
"Prydain Chronicles?"
I see you all nodding.
You know exactly.
You're thinking of
Orddu, Orwen, and Orgoch.
And I said, oh, I did.
I loved those books.
I read them so many times,
I have them practically
memorized, when I was a kid.
So it's probably that.
That's probably
where this came from.
But I was not conscious
of that at all,
which is-- that's
kind of the funny way
that the things that
you read kind of
influence you
without your knowing.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
they were CJ Cherry's Methane
Breathers, but.
ANN LECKIE: There was that, too.
Yeah, CJ Cherry's Methane
Breathers are fabulous.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So who sees your
stuff while you're writing it?
Do you have a writer's
group that you work with?
Do you have beta readers?
ANN LECKIE: I used to have
a writers group in town,
and then a couple of
people moved out of town.
Now, I have a couple
of friends who
live in town, who, when I'm
feeling super insecure, which
totally happens like the first
couple chapters, and I'm like,
is this even worth writing?
This is just a thing
that writers have.
Sometimes new writers are like,
this means I'm not any good.
No, it means you're a writer.
And so then I go
to them, and I go,
these are my first
three chapters.
Is this any good?
And they're like, yeah,
just go finish it,
which is what I need to hear.
And then I will give
them the manuscript,
and they'll make comments.
I don't always-- and any of
y'all who are aspiring fiction
writers, people who
give you comments,
they're worth thinking about
and trying to think about where
those comments came from.
But do not just take the
advice that they give you,
because nine times out
of 10, they're wrong.
When they say, oh,
this isn't working.
You need to explain this more.
Actually, nine
times out of 10, you
need to take away
the sentence that
makes them ask the question.
Or this character is not
realistic, and you're like,
but they should be.
There's one tiny sentence
like two chapters back
that is leading the
reader astray somewhere.
So don't just delete things
when your commenters say
delete something or whatever.
But I find that
fairly important,
but I don't rely on
it as much as I did
when I was just starting out.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I wonder, so as a
fairly inexperienced parent,
I'm wondering how you carve
out time and the ability
to have complex thoughts,
and how do you do it,
while there's a tiny human
throwing blueberries at you?
ANN LECKIE: It's
difficult, isn't it?
Or my son had a thing for
pushing buttons and plugging
and unplugging things.
[LAUGHTER]
I learned to save
frequently, yes.
It's much easier when
they go to school,
which I knew it was kind
of a cop-out answer.
But also to a certain extent,
I started writing seriously
in earnest, partly because I was
home with the children, who--
my children, probably
like your children,
were the most adorable
small children
in the history of
small children.
I will fight anybody who
tells me to the contrary.
And it was great to
be home with them,
but they did not provide very
intellectually stimulating
conversation.
I could talk all I
wanted about Teletubbies.
Teletubbies were big
in my house, Barney.
But eventually, I felt like
my brains were leaking out
my ears, and so to
a certain extent,
that kind of thinking
about stories--
excuse me-- was sort of
self-defense to begin with.
I didn't actually do much
in the way of writing,
until my daughter was away
at school during the day,
and my son could take naps.
My husband worked
nights at the time,
and so I would lay my toddler
son in bed next to his dad.
And then I would
go to Starbucks,
and then, eventually,
I came back
to consistently discover my
son playing in the living room
by himself.
And then I enrolled
him in preschool
so that I could continue to
write just a couple of hours
in the morning.
But I'm not going to lie.
It's really hard when you've
got the little folks at home,
because you're lucky to
have a shower by yourself.
And you can't give full
attention to other things,
because those little kids get
in a lot of trouble, right?
Yeah, there was also the keys
in the outlet the one day.
I mean, yeah.
The whole house went dark.
Yeah, it was amazing.
And my kids were
pretty good kids,
but you have to kind
of keep track of them.
So it's the most amazing thing
when your youngest finally
goes to kindergarten.
You're like, I'm free.
I can actually think about
things and do things.
So my advice would be
while they're little,
store up all the thoughts,
the random little thoughts
that you have.
Keep them in a notebook.
Keep them in the
back of your mind.
And then, when you
do get to the point
where the kiddos are at
school or daycare or whatever,
then take advantage
of that time.
Don't worry about the freaking
laundry, anything like that.
The clothes aren't
going to explode
if you don't wash them today.
So just walk out of the
house, and sit down,
and work on whatever,
because that's important.
You need to get your
brains working back again.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I haven't
read the new book yet,
but I'm kind of curious,
what percentage of the book
is sort of dedicated to
discussion, preparation,
and consumption of tea?
ANN LECKIE: I would say 0%,
except there's one character,
who does arrive and complains
that she cannot find a good cup
of tea.
But I wanted very much--
the other night at a bookstore
event, a person said to me,
this main character is almost
like the complete opposite
of Breq.
How much of that
was just you wanted
to write something that was
totally unlike the trilogy?
And I said, pretty
much all of it.
So I just-- I was
like, all right,
this is going to be
different, so no tea.
Protagonist is going
to be very different.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is tea something you drink a
lot of while you're writing?
ANN LECKIE: Oh, yes.
Tea is something
I drink a lot of.
One of the-- I love
traveling and meeting people,
but one of the downsides
is it's very difficult
to find a good cup of tea
while you're on the road,
because it's not a thing that
Americans typically-- it's
becoming more, which is awesome.
Tea is kind of becoming
more fashionable,
and you can find more
places that serve it.
But hotel rooms
do not necessarily
provide you with good tea,
so I'm looking forward
to getting home and being
able to sit down and have
a cup, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I haven't read,
actually, any of your work,
and I'm looking
forward to it now.
I'm going to read
this one first,
because it's what's in my hands.
So given what you
were just saying
about how this is the
opposite, or you were sort
of trying to lean
the other direction
from the previous trilogy,
when I finish this one,
if I go to pick up
your trilogy, what
would you say to prepare me?
ANN LECKIE: Oh, that's-- so the
trilogy is much more serious
and intense, particularly
the first book.
The mood is very different,
and the protagonist
is very different and presents
in a far more grim way.
So that would probably be
the biggest difference.
But other than that, I think
if you enjoy this, which
is meant to be a standalone
for precisely that reason,
you could probably enter into
the trilogy pretty easily,
I would imagine.
AUDIENCE: So you're not going
to warn me off of it completely?
ANN LECKIE: Oh, no.
Buy and read all
my books, please.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what are
you working on next?
ANN LECKIE: Oh, I am
working on a thing,
but I'm not at the point where
I really can talk about it yet.
But I will as soon as I can.
AUDIENCE: So something.
ANN LECKIE: Something, yeah.
I am working on another book.
Let me put it that
way, because if I
say I'm working on something,
it sounds like I've got--
I'm working on a movie.
I'm writing comic books.
No, it's nothing that
earth-shattering.
I am working on another book.
It's just too early
to talk about yet.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What is serbat?
ANN LECKIE: What is serbat?
So it's not tea.
AUDIENCE: Is it
a tea substitute?
ANN LECKIE: It's not tea.
AUDIENCE: Almost but
not entirely unlike tea?
ANN LECKIE: Almost but
not entirely unlike tea.
There's actually a real
world drink I named it after.
There's a drink.
I found it in the
international grocery at home
called Serbat Wangi.
And it's an instant thing,
comes in little packets,
and it's got sugar and cloves
and black pepper and ginger,
and it makes a nice,
little hot drink.
And I said, well,
OK, it's not tea,
and I'll use that, because it's
actually kind of good tasting.
AUDIENCE: And do you survive by
bringing your own tea with you
on tour?
ANN LECKIE: I often do.
I haven't this time around.
I actually have a little
travel tea kettle.
That's how desperate I am.
But I did not bring it on this
tour, because it's so long.
And I packed with
extreme efficiency,
and there was no way that little
kettle was getting in there.
AUDIENCE: Because if
you're looking for some,
there's a tea bar just
through back there.
ANN LECKIE: Oh, thank you.
Thank you very much.
I think we have time
for another question.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So you have a book, your first
book with, literally, "justice"
in the title and are fairly
active about social issues
on Twitter.
How does that kind of
affect both your writing
and your professional life?
AUDIENCE: So I actually--
you're right.
I am active with social
issues and stuff on Twitter.
Lately, it's a lot
of angry retweeting,
but I don't generally
start out saying,
I want to write a book
about this social issue.
I always start
out saying, I want
to write a book with this fun
thing, with spider mechs in it,
with ships that take over human
bodies, with space battles,
because who doesn't
love space battles?
And then, because I am,
frankly, easily bored,
I need to have something
to really think about
while I'm working on a project.
I get very unsatisfied
with things
that are just lots of noise.
Sometimes that's what
you want to read,
but if I'm going
to write a book,
I need to have more
to think about.
And then, at that
point, I start digging
into the motifs and the
things that I'm writing about,
and it's difficult for me not
to think about my politics,
how that intersects with
what the story is saying.
I personally believe
that narrative
is extraordinarily
powerful, because it's
a basic mode of human thought.
It's how we analyze
the world around us.
And the narratives that
we have in our inventory
influence how we're going
to respond to the world.
We see a thing,
and we're like, we
need to make a
pattern out of that.
Here's a pattern.
Here's a template.
All right, everything fits, and
then you act according to that.
And sometimes you
can pick a template
that can literally end up
with somebody getting killed.
And I would never
tell writers to write
particular kinds of stories,
but I feel that as a writer,
it's very important to
think about the stories
that I'm putting out,
because those are potentially
people's templates.
And I don't want to be
saying something that I
would regret having said.
So I do think very
hard about those things
when I write the story,
but I don't sit down
to write a story
that tells somebody
about my political beliefs about
something, if that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Thank you.
ANN LECKIE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]